the starting quarterback of the
Tennessee Titans one of the hottest
cubies in the league and we are thrilled
to have him here on the show he greatly
appreciate prior to a big game against
the Oakland Raiders this weekend he's
Ryan Tannehill how are you sir
hey I'm doing great I are you sure are
man you sure are very rare does do I
start an interview with how does it feel
but I think that is a a great way to
start based on the journey to to have
you call in with the last six weeks that
you've had yeah it's it's fun you know
it's uh been a kind of a wild season for
me you know a different situation to
start the year but uh it's been fun last
six weeks and having a lot of fun have a
lot of confidence and the guys around me
and uh you know big opportunity in front
of us just taking it one game at a time
yep and so when you why did you decide
to sign with the Titans walk me through
your
non-playing season decision-making Ryan
you know I actually got treated here Oh
little-known fact but I demonstrated
here and uh and so didn't really have a
whole lot of option right I forgot about
but uh but it worked out well
so when you was so one you got traded to
Tennessee what was going through your
mind well I knew I was coming in you
know primarily the sign is it back up
and and be ready as my opportunity was
called
you know so that was a different
situation for me you know tough tough
for the offseason and and really you
know going into the season you know it
was an adjustment and uh just had to
kind of find my way you know it was all
new for me so you know leaning on some
guys that that I've played with in the
past and former players and you know
tried to make the best in situation be
ready if my number's called and then try
to help out as much as I could and uh
you know finally got my opportunity and
like I said having a lot of fun sense
who did you lean on specifically a Matt
Moore was one guy did just because I
played for so long with him in Miami he
was such a great backup for me you know
over six years in Miami
that's just great job supporting me and
always seemed to play well when he when
he did go in so you know time respect
for Matt and obviously he's got some
playing time this year in Kansas City
and happy for him it is amazing the
journeys are amazed
Ryan right I mean Matt was he was just
he was a teacher he was he was he was at
Cuyler Murray's protei man I mean like
that right
it simply he uh you know we're still
good friends and I was talking to him
and before the season started he's like
yeah you know I'm coaching or whatever
you know we want to come visit you guys
I was thinking you know maybe
mid-november before Thanksgiving
something like that and uh turns out the
game that they were thinking about
coming to was Kansas City little did he
know he's gonna be there in about three
weeks and and coming coming here anyways
that's amazing so what what advice did
he give you that you were able to take
to heart that that got you prepared for
the season in the manner that uh that
you you liked yeah I think his main
point was just you know go go have fun
and uh you know do the best you can
preparing you know have fun on the scout
team you get the try stuff that that you
would normally try you know if you're
you're running the the first team reps
you know you're basically looking at a
card and going out trying to execute so
you can try throws try situations that
you would normally try in a game or
anything like that and kind of figure
out you know if you can bring anything
into your game and at the same time I
just take a ton of mental reps when
you're watching watching tape and
watching from the back whenever whatever
the first team is going Ryan Tannehill
Titans starting quarterback going into a
big game against the Raiders in the
black hole joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show three head coaches five
offensive coordinators in eight years
best I can tell is that an accurate
rundown of what you've had since coming
off the paper so I think so it all kind
of runs together it was a lot of
craziness down there but uh but yeah it
was a wild ride but you know like you
said big game this week for us and we're
excited for the opportunity we are no I
know you want to look down the road if
you don't mind just one last on the
Wayback Machine do you think you got a
fair shake in the first few years of
your career Ryan yeah I'm not I'm not
gonna criticize you know as a learning
journey for me you know I learned a lot
I grew up a lot you know as a player as
a person as a leader just just
everything that happened to me you know
down
I mean good bad the ugly and everything
in between like I said learned a lot and
definitely could carry that forward you
know as as this thing goes sure what is
the one thing you did learn if you could
just pull out the most important thing
that you did learn from from 2012
through 2018 for you I mean I went so
many lessons it's tough to pull one
thing but just off the top of my head is
is control each control and make the
best of whatever situation you're in and
be the best person a football player you
can be you know there's a lot of things
that go on you know in the building
outside of the building and the media
the fans and at the end of the day you
have to like I said do what you can do
to to be the best man and football
player you can be Ryan Tannehill here on
the Rich Eisen show okay so how is
variable different from the guys that
have coached you in the NFL Oh
I mean variables unique you know he's a
he's a former player I think he's the
only you know former player that's a
head coach at a place where obviously
played a long time have a ton of respect
for him as a player you know I remember
watching him catch touchdowns when I was
a kid you know was it with the Patriots
you can seem like every time he was in
he was catching a touchdown in right
don't don't uh don't forget he doesn't
let us forget it so what do you mean oh
he's constantly reminding us about his
touchdown ratio in touchdown catches and
all that so we're just in and just but
it's uh it's fun you know he's a he's a
great leader he does a good job of
setting the tone from the front of the
room a day in and day out what he
expects from us and and just
communicating you know across the board
of of what we expect as a team as an
offense defense and special teams yeah I
mean well you're a converted receiver
right Ryan I mean you've got some
touchdown catches yourself from your I
do I was a very very long time ago for
sure but it just really is amazing how
how things work out what about because
you said obviously Matt Moore and you
had a strong relationship based on the
past what about you and Mariota
obviously this is the franchise that
drafted him second overall a couple
years after you came into the league
what does that Ben
like with you and for you Ryan yeah
Marcus is doing great we have a great
relationship obviously the extremely
tough situation for him you know being
drafted here being here you know five
years and he has his roots here and you
know everyone in the building loves them
you know I love him he's a he's a great
man and a good football player so out of
respect for Marcus and and the person he
is so he's handled this situation like a
true professional
like I said tough tough situation but it
comes to work every day does the best he
can and supports me along the way so
definitely uh you know my respect has
only grown for Marcus through this
process and what's it like in the huddle
with luan you know Taylor's a fellow
Michigan man I've had him on this show
quite a bit he's got his own podcast he
has it in a bus that doesn't move with
no motor but what is it do you have to
calm him down sometimes right not in the
huddle it's more like after the play
before we get to that all usually by the
time we're in the huddle he's uh he's
calmed down I was like you know everyone
kind of knows what Taylor is and he's an
emotional player plays a lot of energy
and passion and uh yeah there's been a
few times where he's John with the
player or or thinking about you know
getting into something extracurricular
ya don't have to have to pull back the
reins a little bit
well yeah like I said guys extremely
talented place was a ton of energy and
passion and you know that's translate to
the translates to the guys around him as
well have you been on his project have
you done it I have not I have not yet he
he mentioned it a while back but we
haven't haven't landed up yet I know I
just he's asked me just so you know why
I haven't been on yet is I refuse to go
on his bus and with the boys podcast
Ryan until the bus moves you know what I
mean like that's the idea that's
probably fair right because right now
it's not it shouldn't be considered a
bus it's just a room that happens to be
looking like a bus if he's if he puts a
motor in it and it drives that's that's
when I won't actually be on the pod it's
it's basically a non-functioning trailer
yes you know exactly but I don't think
that the podcast could be called what
did you call it a non-functioning
trailer
you can't call it ring to it does it
know non-functioning trailing with the
Boyd's does not I don't think people are
gonna be downloading that for sure
probably not I'm just going through you
know I'm trying to say off the top my
head but I can't remember is this gonna
be your first visit to the black hole or
have you been there before Ryan it is my
first visit I'm excited you know I think
I've been to almost every every stadium
at this point so played Oakland
obviously several times I think the one
the one time was an Oakland home game
was actually in London I think that was
in 2014 but uh but yes I'm excited for
the opportunity to go out experience the
black hole so is it it would it be fair
to say that you're playing with house
money here and by that I mean the fact
that you can if you wish make your own
decision on your destination by the end
of the year and you are getting an
opportunity that perhaps you didn't
think you would have handed to you to
start let alone to start for a team
that's on a such a terrific roll with a
chance to make the playoffs and go
beyond is it is it fair to call that you
are playing with house money right now
Ryan Tannehill yeah I don't know about
that I know I'm excited and thankful for
the opportunity you know I like he said
I didn't know what really was gonna
gonna happen when I signed here you know
primarily backup Marcus and I knew I
wanted to be ready in case you know god
forbid he got injured or an opportunity
arose so I'm thankful for the
opportunity I'm excited for you know
what we have in front of us here you
know with this uh this game up in
Oakland you know it's going to be a
tough stretch here to in the Air Force
and we're gonna have to play well you
know we're only on the right track we
haven't finished anything yet so just
have to keep it going and we'll see what
happens and have you given any thought
to your own personal contractual
situation no I mean at this point in
time I can't control any of that so I'm
just trying to go out and and play the
best football can and leave this team to
win and I feel like actually I know that
the rest will take care of itself
alright and you got a good Marino's
story and all right you got a good one
uh most of marino stories are a little
too lively I think for Public Radio
really no kidding no I mean now just
kidding uh-huh a lot of a lot of good
ones but I guess here's the best advice
not the best advice but uh one of the
first things Marino told me you know I'm
like idiot you know Dan you know
anything uh if you can tell me you can
help me out he's like a guy just pick
your guy and let it fly just pick your
guy and let it fly that's what Dan
Marino
that's it pick a guy and let it fly how
cool is that the Dan Marino would say
that to you right like you're talking
about that looks great you know just
having him around you know he was around
a lot you know for several years there
in Miami so just having him around
talking talking ball with him and always
had a great one-liner to throw at us so
well good have a Dan around Dan I
assumed you were an Ace Ventura pet
detective fan as well correct what I see
no question I mean I was like middle of
my right and there you are for the
Dolphins where you know we're ray Finkle
that laces out and now Dan Marino's
telling you to t just pick your guy and
let it fly that's so cool
that is pretty hey Ryan thanks for
calling in I know you don't do this
stuff very often and I appreciate you
accepting our invitation I've enjoyed
watching the last six weeks I'm always
about the journey and you've got an
incredible opportunity in front of you
so good luck with that
Thanks you got it when you see LaJuan
later today ask him if he's got the
engine for his bus yet will you please I
will he'll probably have some lame
excuse don't worry I understood I
understood take care of yourself man all
right thank you guys Ryan Tannehill
titans quarterback for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app